après avoir animé la première table
ronde ce n'est pas la chose la plus
difficile qui soit cher nicolas monsieur
le président de vous faire la lecture
des questions qui vont résumé le
programme ambitieux vous l'aurez bien
compris qui vient d'être présentée par
le président notre mouvement donc une
douzaine de questions que sur lesquels
vous pourrez vous prononcer comme cela a
été rappelé à partir de ce soir 18h
première question doit-on libérer les
policiers gendarmes des contraintes
administratives qui pèsent sur eux afin
qu'ils puissent se recentrer sur leur
métier ordre public investigations
renseignements dans la lutte contre la
délinquance
deuxième question faut-il étendre les
compétences des policiers municipaux
accès à certains fichiers de police et
contrôles d'identité pour en faire de
véritables partenaires de sécurité aux
côtés des policiers et des gendarmes
troisièmement l'armement des polices
municipales dans une ville de plus de
10000 habitants doit-il être de droit
sauf opposition du conseil municipal ce
qui inverse la tendance à l'heure
actuelle
quatrième question à l'exemple des
interdits de stade
faut-il permettre aux maires d'interdire
temporairement à des individus fauteurs
de trouble de paraître dans certains
lieux pour des motifs de présente de
prévention à la tranquillité publique
cinquième question êtes vous favorable à
une nouvelle législation sur la
présomption de légitime défense des
policiers et gendarmes dans l' usage de
leurs armes afin de sécuriser leurs
interventions
sixièmement souhaitez vous la
construction de plus de 20000 places de
prison supplémentaires pour adapter
notre système carcéral à la réalité de
la délinquance 7e m'en fous qu'il mette
fin à l'aménagement systématique des
courtes peines de prison ainsi qu'à tous
les mécanismes de réductions
automatiques de peine pour redonner tout
son sens à la sanction 8e question les
peines planchers abrogée en 2014 par le
gouvernement doivent être telle remise
en place pour les récidivistes et les
réitérant 9e question l'administration
pénitentiaire et les douanes doivent
être elle rattachée au ministère de
l'intérieur pour améliorer le pilotage
des forces de sécurité y compris en
prison
dixième question faut-il et l'art
le champ de rétention de sûreté aux
terroristes sortant de prison pour
permettre la surveillance et d'isolement
descente de déradicalisation à l'issue
de leur peine en fonction de leur
dangerosité
11e question avant la multiplication des
campements illégaux
faut-il donner davantage de pouvoirs à
l'état pour les faire évacuer en urgence
et rétablir l'ordre républicain
et enfin dernière question faut-il
refondre la justice des mineurs autour
d'un code pénal spécifique en marquant
une véritable césure entre la justice de
la famille et des enfants et la justice
pénale des mineurs pour redonner tout
son sens à la sanction
je vous remercie